foreign
[Music]
binsberg and a finance professor at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania and I'm Jonathan Burke a
financial professor at The Graduate
School of Business at Stanford
University and this is the all else
equal podcast
welcome back everybody today we're going
to do something a little different
neither Jews nor I are experts in
digital currencies and both of us are
confused by the news and the hype around
Central Bank digital currencies so what
we decided to do in this episode is ask
a world expert one of my colleagues at
Stanford Kevin Walsh to come and talk
about it and see if we can jointly learn
something about Central Bank digital
currencies
before we turn to Kevin let's just
quickly go over what a currency is well
so the first question related to that is
why can a piece of paper that has no
intrinsic value have any use or any
value in transactions why Jonathan are
you letting me pay you with a piece of
paper that has no intrinsic value and I
think that the answer is not too
difficult suppose that I wanted to buy
your house and I was going to pay you
with an amount of gold of the equivalent
value now given the fact that I don't
want to be carrying this gold around I
just have to Gold stored at the bank and
the bank has given me a piece of paper
that says the owner of this piece of
paper can anytime come and claim this
amount of gold
now given the fact that you have no
intention of carrying the gold around
either and you just want to have
possession of the gold all I have to do
is give you the piece of paper that says
that you can go and claim the gold and
so we can pay each other with an
intrinsically worthless piece of paper
as long as that piece of paper
represents a claim to something else the
gold that is stored in the bank and I
can buy your house with that piece of
paper from you so Jules that's a good
example and it works for the gold
standard but we're no longer on the goal
standard so how does it work in modern
economies
well so as it turns out what gives a
piece of paper value and the dollar in
particular is that through taxes the U.S
government has a claim on all of the
production that we jointly make because
all of us need to pay a fraction of what
we produce as taxes to the government
and because you're allowed to pay your
taxes with these pieces of paper and
they're because the taxes are a claim on
underlying goods and because the piece
of paper allows you to pay the taxes
which in turns are a claim in the
underlying Goods we still have something
real that backs the dollar
and that is the fact that you can pay
your taxes with it and so what backing
the dollar is essentially the production
of the United States but part of that is
a promise by the government not to issue
more dollars and change the ratio of how
many dollars they are to consumption and
so I would say that one of the reasons
the dollar is a reserve currency if
people have a lot of trust that the
government of the United States won't
inflate the money supply and devalue the
currency indeed I think that the main
thing that we'll have to talk today
about also with Kevin is the value of
distrust where this trust comes from and
whether or not that trust currently is
under threat because what we're hearing
all the time now today is and that is
the topic of today's episode is that we
somehow need to go digital and that for
some reason digital dollars are
different than real dollars
I don't really understand it because the
US dollar is essentially already a
digital currency very little of U.S
dollars is in banknotes almost all US
dollars are in electronic form so in
what sense would the dollar need to be
digital it's already digital
no that is true because indeed a very
small fraction is only currently held in
cash but I think that what people
generally talk about is that for some
reason we need to record these
transactions differently and so the
whole revolution of blockchain implies
that the way that we do transactions
with each other with dollars would be
somehow recorded differently than in the
centralized system that we've had so far
so how does this centralized system work
suppose that I pay you Jonathan sixty
dollars then both of our banks have a
list with transactions on it and my bank
adds a transaction that says that I have
sixty dollars less and your bank has a
list of transactions assess the due of
sixty dollars more but other than those
two Banks there is no record of this
financial transaction taking place
between the two of us and so the idea of
blockchain which is a decentralized
ledger is that there are all these
different copies out there of this this
list so that it can be verified through
say consensus mechanism that this
transaction between the two of us has
taken place and so when we're talking
about a digital currency I think on the
blockchain I think this is what people
have in mind yes I think you're right
Jules I think what they have in mind is
a blockchain so it's not just that the
currency is digital but that it's
controlled by a blockchain and there
again I'm like you I don't really
understand why we have a need for that
because you know I would say part of the
reason the United States is such a
successful country is because we have
trust we have ledgers that we trust and
these organizations have been built up
over time and I don't see any reason why
we need to doubt that system of trust
no I completely agree so so when I ask
my students how many of you have looked
at their checking account recently and
have doubted what the amount was that
was reported there and it doesn't bother
you at all that your bank is the one who
keeps track of this and do you really
wish that there were hundreds of
different copies out there so that it
could be verified through a consensus
mechanism whether or not your amount on
your account is correct yes or no and I
don't think any of my students
particularly in the US as you mentioned
ever ever say that that is an issue for
them although I think we can certainly
think of other countries where that
might be a concern where record-keeping
of property rights might have a bigger
application than it has in the United
States but that said Jonathan I do think
you would agree that the United States
payment system is quite Antiquated right
that is true that is definitely true and
I don't necessarily why this is a
solution to that problem but it is true
that it takes an enormously long time
for me to pay you and internationally
it's it's a nightmare
all right so with all of these questions
because I don't think we've answered
anything really Jonathan all we've done
here is asked questions but I think that
a person who can help us answer these
questions would be Kevin wash so let me
introduce Our Guest Kevin Walsh is a
member of the Board of Governors of the
Federal Reserve from 2006 to 2011.
he was also on the shortlist for Fed
chair when ultimately Jerome Powell was
appointed he's a colleague of Mine He's
The Shepherd family distinguished
visiting fellow in economics at
Stanford's Hoover institution and a
lecturer at The Graduate School of
Business Kevin Welcome to our show well
it's it's great to be Jonathan with you
and Jules
so Kevin you're not even looking at this
most daughters are already digital so
why bother with a new digital currency
uh this is a fertile subject certainly
made more fertile by the by the ongoing
geopolitical fights between and among
adversaries and allies around the world
yes it's true stipulate to your fact
Jonathan that commercial bank money is
largely digital and Commercial Bank
money rather central bank money is
dominant but I think that that's really
only the tip of the iceberg my
suggestion is that there be a central
bank digital currency but it'd be quite
different from that which is much
discussed among government authorities
that is it's confined to the wholesale
Market there ought not be a retail
facing consumer-facing Central Bank
digital currency for recent both of
politics and economics but in answer
your question
I think of the new technology as nothing
but amazing new software that every 17
year old computer scientist that shows
up at Stanford will only be working with
will be the dominant use and that new
software lets us do things at the
wholesale level which are faster cheaper
better smarter and will give the
countries that adopt it a comparative
advantage
and finally if you have the benefit of
having the world's Reserve currency as
your as your Tailwind you'd even be at
the bleeding edge but you also not you
shouldn't be the last mover and I take
more seriously than some in our
profession than the US needs to
constantly ensure that well dollars the
world's Reserve currency remains so for
the next hundred years and I don't want
to fall too far away from the efficient
Frontier
so Kevin it seems that and I think
you've also written about this
extensively in various places also in
the Wall Street Journal that one thing
that you're particularly worried about
is that the dollar would lose its
Reserve currency and particularly that
it would lose it to the Chinese RMB and
given the fact that China has decided to
already introduce a central bank digital
currency that could be a worry that we
should all be worried about now you said
that there is a competitive battle going
on you said it's it's very Advanced
software but what do you think it
wouldn't take for the us to lose its
Reserve currency status and do you
really think that just not having a
central bank digital currency on its own
is enough for the us to lose it or would
other circumstances be required as well
it would probably be other circumstances
too but I worry that the dollar is
losing just below the surface some of
its credibility some of its strength and
that has little to do with the new
software that has everything to do with
does the world look at the U.S as the
bright shining City upon the hill that
knows how to grow its economy that knows
how to ensure productivity and I think
the world does look at us differently
less enamored than they did the day
before the 08 crisis the day before the
pandemic even during the post-pandemic
slog we've been through to this point
and so the most important thing for the
dollar is to have good economic policies
in place and I think there's huge
reforms that could be undertaken second
most important thing is to treat our
allies well try to encourage them to be
part of this sphere of influence
dominated by the U.S but has made the
world I apologize for this old-fashioned
view a source of peace and prosperity
for the globe so that the dollar is a
global public good but on the margin
these other things do matter and I do
think that going to market with the
dollar with a payment system and a set
of backbone technologies that are stuck
in the 1970s
that are unreliable that are slow that
are expensive that have allowed
oligopolists to benefit without letting
those benefits accrue to the broad users
of the system that's an unnecessary
asset to be stuck with and so when I see
this new technology this blockchain
technology being employed by both
adversaries and allies in various forms
it says this is an easy way to put some
points on the on the board and to lead
the global economy at least on this over
the next for the 21st century and just
as a final Point whether we like it or
not Jules and Jonathan the world is
breaking into what appears to be at
least two series of influence yes glibly
I'd call them hours and theirs and in
theirs China wants to have their own
payment system wants to have their own
currency for those that want to do
business in their sphere of influence
and I think they would have preferred
that people join their sphere of
influence out of choice but if they
won't join that sphere of influence out
of choice maybe they'll do it out of
compulsion if you want to Source Goods
in that sphere if you want to sell
products to consumers in that sphere
they might well say that you need to
separate yourself from the dollar and do
it in this digital RMB
and I view that as a catalyst hopefully
for our policy makers to at least move
from 1970s technology and LeapFrog to a
new technology so that doing business in
the dollar is true not just in our
sphere of influence when you're working
directly with the us but continues to be
the dominant currency for the world I
think that accrues advantages to the US
but I also think it a cruise advantages
to everyone that would be participants
in the dollar block around the world
I'm not sure I agree with all your
arguments I'm not sure it has to do with
the digital currency I agree our payment
system is a 1970 payment system but why
do we need blockchain why can't we just
bring the payment system into the 21st
century
we could and if you asked our colleagues
that are working at the Federal Reserve
and the treasury they would say they are
making incremental progress in and
around things like fed now making
settlements faster making the messaging
system more apparent so you can track
your transactions Etc a policy of
incrementalism is better than the status
quo but I think if you believe what I do
which is the U.S and global economy are
going to look radically different 10 and
20 years from now the world we grew up
with which is one of integrated Global
markets integrated trade and capital
flows we might have seen at least for
quite a while the high point of that if
there were ever a chance to move Beyond
incrementalism so that we could have
payments settlements programmable money
and a new way of doing business and
LeapFrog it strikes me this is the
moment but in some sense if the other
side is going to be using compulsion to
try to do business in a particular
currency and make it a reserve currency
the question is whether these soft
measures are going to be enough to stop
that in any case wouldn't you say
so I don't think we'll be able to stop
what they demand of customers in their
block who want to do business with their
customers yep but I think what we can do
and here I'm going to paraphrase General
McMaster which I'll apply it to the
monetary context something he applies in
the political and Military context
what we're saying to people that have a
choice of regimes you can choose your
own sovereignty versus subservience
we believe that if you participate in
this new payment system and you continue
to use the dollar in your transactions
whether the US is directly involved or
not
you can build on this system whatever
apis whatever programmable money
whatever bells and whistles you want and
you can have control over your own
payments and I think that choice of
freedom is a superior choice to these
are the rules that you must go down and
again that's why I would rather not make
the choice between
a modern effective compulsory system
which might be the future of the digital
R B versus you choose that or you choose
a unreliable lazy stubborn expensive
system which has been the dollar block
going on 40 or 50 years I want the
competition to be a better competition
so Kevin I'm going to push back a little
bit and let me say this my view is that
one of the reasons that dollar is a
world reserved currency is trust that
the United States has an incredibly high
level of trust and that's built up over
a very long time given this current
systems and that I don't worry about the
r b ever being a reserve currency
precisely because their trust doesn't
exist
so why would you want to replace that
with a system we're not certain about
the trust I mean all the institutions
the United States have been built up to
ensure their trust how do we know under
the new system we would have our trust
so if you trying to pick a fight on
trust you're not going to find me
choosing the other side of it so I let
you believe that the American dollar
denominated post-war system is
predicated on trust I worry that some of
that trust in institutions has eroded
generally and has arrived in the U.S
particularly
so I don't seek to replace a system
based on trust with something that is
fashionable
untrustworthy but cool I want to replace
that with a system which is more
trustworthy I want to build that
transaction so it is more trustworthy so
it is fully auditable not so that it's
in the underground so that it's above
ground so that transaction happens
seamlessly if there's a bad actor the
audit Trail is there for all of us to
see so in my view the new system is
enhancing of trust and reliability and
if the question is well no one has
really built out yet an effective
scalable digital currency that is used
by everyone around that's absolutely
true but that's not a reason to stick
with the old technology agreed but I do
think there's a deeper question here and
the deeper question is this the main
advantage in my opinion of blockchain is
that it is a decentralized ledger
instead of a centralized manager and so
the question is why do we need many
copies of a decentralized piece of
information rather than a centralized
version of that piece of information and
I do think that the basic idea that
people would have for that is that it's
harder to commit fraud with a
decentralized statute and with a
centralized Ledger if that isn't the
main benefit then I would like to know
what would be the main benefit and then
we get back to what Jonathan pointed out
earlier which was if we just want to
bring competition in line with an
old-fashioned system up to speed with
technology is the decentralized feature
really the feature that we should be
going after or is it more something
about how quickly transactions can be
cleared and things like that which of
course can be done in many different
ways so I do think that the FTX fraud
does make it clear that this system is
just as much subject to fraud as any
other system and then what was the
purpose of doing it this way to begin
with then isn't that fair yeah Jules it
is fair so let's go into the three
levels of that question as I distilled
it one is is the FTX fraud about fraud
and build out of a decentralized network
or was the fraud done all centrally I
don't know the forensic accounting to
that yep but I'm very surprised given
what I read in the newspaper I have no
privileged information that any of this
was actually done on the blockchain that
any of this is in a perfect auditable
Trail when this investigation from the
SEC and the justice department others
are done I think they're going to see
the equivalent of wires written from one
account to another and it will it will
have very little to do with the
blockchain but that's my speculation
that's my judgment I don't think these
guys had enough built out it looks uh to
suggest that this was done on some
auditable chain if so the prosecutors
will have the easiest job to do in the
history white collar crime yep so that's
a factual question I'm just asserting a
premise based on what I've read secondly
on the payment system I mean this is the
old joke but it's true it is now faster
easier and more reliable for a Brazilian
to put a million dollars in cash in a
suitcase board a plane from Rio
come to the United States go through all
the Customs forms and deposit it at Bank
of New York Mellon then it would have
been to send that transaction through
the existing payment system it would
have taken days longer would have been
more expensive to do it so we're
actually still bringing these atoms
across borders yeah there's huge
benefits the third question I think is a
good and important both philosophical
and structural question about
centralized versus decentralized so
here's what I'm proposing in what I
describe as a wholesale only Central
Bank digital currency it's decentralized
in the sense that we're using the
blockchain as the base Foundation to
conduct this business the trail is
auditable the money can only be sent
once and only once and he changes the
block would have to be seen inside out
of the block it could happen
instantaneously and if some Court had a
warrant that it was being done for bad
aims you'd be able to see that
distributed Ledger perfectly
what's the piece of this that in my
intellectual model is centralized the
fed and the treasury say this is the
profit framework these are the rails
we'll be using and we will all be using
these same rails if you want this to be
backed by the full faith and credit of
the U.S and the dollars Reserve currency
you can't build your own bespoke system
we don't want there to be dozens and
hundreds of these working in parallel I
was plenty worried about that direction
so Kevin one of the things you've
written about is that you favor stable
coins and you favor regulation of state
requirements but I wouldn't say Bank
regulation is one of our prize and joys
I I would say that if anything were
pretty bad at regulating backs so why
would you want us to regulate yet
another Financial instance
I disagree with the words you just
purported to put in my mouth
I am incredibly uncomfortable with the
idea which has been gaining Traction in
Washington but stable coins are fine so
long as they're we regulate them like a
bank I think this is a dangerous and bad
idea I want to be very clear on that so
I think broadly the idea of taking the
stable coins that are out and about
subjecting them to bank regulation is a
bad idea why because Bank regulation is
imperfect and two when you're regulating
something that purports to be the US
dollar and it fails
in my view the political economy makes
it such that you almost assuredly have
to bail it out because you don't want
the dollar to be falling in its Prestige
and its privilege you don't want there
to be people that say I wonder if that
dollar is really worth it after all so I
am uncomfortable with the idea of a
regulatory framework as the Panacea for
stable coins and in that at least in the
pre FTX days my voice seemed to be in
the minority large number of thoughtful
legislators from both parties seem
positively inclined to that idea and I
will say it worried me and continues to
worry me tremendously
well thank you very much Kevin yeah it
was great Kevin so Jonathan I think that
was a pretty interesting conversation I
learned a lot of new things there you
know Jules I was pretty convinced by his
argument that the government has a role
in setting up the rails so if they set
up a digital currency which is just
rails and allow private Enterprise to do
whatever that want with it that sounds
like a pretty good thing for government
to do yeah I couldn't agree with you
more Jonathan government providing
infrastructure while giving to private
sector all the room it wants to be
entrepreneurial I think that's exactly
what one would want
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at Apple podcast we'd love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
Next Episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcast for more information and
episodes visit all else equalpodcast.com
or follow us on LinkedIn the ol SQL
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by University FM
[Music]
thank you